trafficking and for other purposes
question is will the house suspend the
rules and pass the bill as amended
members will record their votes by
electronic device
does the gentlelady from north carolina
rise uh
madam speaker as uh the member
designated by miss wilson of florida
pursuant to house res 965
i informed the house that miss wilson
will vote yes on
h.r 5664 the leveraging information on
foreign traffickers act
the gentleman from california rise as a
member designated by mr huffman
pursuant to h resolution
965 i informed the house that mr huffman
will vote yes on the motion to recommit
five six six four
do you know it later
what purpose does the gentleman from
north carolina rise
madam speaker is the member designated
by mr kildee of michigan
pursuant to hres 965. i informed the
house that mr kelly will vote yes
he will vote yes on h.r 5664
what purpose does the gentleman from
california rise
madam speaker is member designated by
congressmember napolitano pursuant to
house resolution 965.
i informed the house that member
napolitano will vote
yes on h.r 5664.
what purpose is the gentleman from new
york rise as the member designated by
congressman jose serrano pursuant to
hres 965.
i informed the house that congressman
serrano will vote yay on
h.r 5664.
as the member designated by chairwoman
zoe lofgren pursuant to hres 965
i informed the house that chairwoman
lofgren will vote yay
on h.r 56 64.